hey sodding I don't know about you but I
haven't slept in 24 hours
Jessica nope and you know but you know
what else doesn't sleep in 24 hours what
news
everyone it's Monday and I'm Justin I'm
Cali Jess and Dan are out today they
were up for over 24 hours streaming for
our 72 hour extra life marathon for the
kids we raised over $15,000 so thank you
to everyone who tuned in and donated so
they can't do the news today so we're
gonna fill in for them
first off cyberpunk 2077 dev CD Projekt
RED has responded to the Star Wars loot
box drama with an incredible tweet some
people were concerned that Witcher 3
developer CD Projekt RED would consider
a games a service model from the highly
anticipated cyberpunk 2077 but the
developer denies this and even took to
Twitter with a strongly worded tweet
dragging pretty much the whole gaming
industry worried not when thinking CP
2077 think nothing less than TW 3 huge
single-player open-world story driven
RPG no hidden catch you get what you pay
for
no [ __ ] just honest gaming like with
the Wild Hunt we leave greed to others
specifically a video by the YouTube
channel pretty good gaming sites an
interview the studio did with Polish
publication strepa in which it indicates
that it wants to make cyberpunk more
commercially successful than The Witcher
3 and suggested that it might use an
online component to achieve that goal
but after a tweet like that it's hard to
be too worried and also related to all
of this Star Wars Luke Fox drama
yes bottom line might also be affected
over the weekend the company's stock
went down by about 2.5 percent while as
of this Monday that's levelled out to
just about a 1% drop it shows that Wall
Street is paying attention to Star Wars
effect on EA for the month overall EA
stock prices down by 7% though for the
full year is actually doing really well
the stock prices up 42 percent this year
while Star Wars has temporarily removed
microtransactions from the game that the
company said in a statement the removal
of microtransactions is quote not
expected to have a material impact on
EA's
fiscal year 2018 financial guidance for
the year ending March 31st 2018 EA
expects to make five point zero 75
billion in revenue and a profit of one
point one three six billion dollars
there's no exact word yet on when micro
transactions will return to Star Wars
Battlefront but it will be bringing the
back into the game in some form at a
later date but that won't be until the
studio has time to make unspecified
changes to the game and finally a
reminder that this weekend is Black
Friday a date that no longer really
means anything all this week and through
the weekend there are going to be a ton
of gaming sales going on at almost every
major retailer and you can keep up with
all of them on GameSpot comm check out
our full roundup of deals both by
console and retailer on the site and for
a little bit of context on where all of
this craziness started we have a
fascinating and kind of frightening
history of Black Friday feature for you
to check out Jess and Dan will be back
tomorrow hopefully after a little bit
more sleep thanks for watching and we'll
catch you next time and if you're
watching this somehow in the future on a
recorded life maybe pray to God this
does not end up somehow published anyway
thank you for enjoying our time
that's no okay